داخليا وعلى الارض يهتز شمال الغربي في
تركيا بسبب زلزال يضرب تلك المناطق
اما خارجيا وعلى الحدود الجنوبيه الشرقيه
تهتز الارض شماليه سوريا والعراق لكن بسبب
اضطرابات الجويه التركيه هناك
العمليه التي وصفت بالاكبر والاشمل
والاكثر فاعليه في شمالي العراق وسوريا
واصفرت عن تحييد 254 مسلحا واصابت 401
هدفا وابقى وزاره الدفاع التركيه
والطائرات بدون طياره ليست والبدايه وعيد
بمزيد من الضربات بموازاه القصف الجوي
والمدفعيه الى زحف القوات البريه وفي
الوقت المناسب بحسب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وذلك ما يخشاه النظام السوري الذي
تتزايد مخاوفه من تكرار الرئيس التركي
تحذيراته من ان جيشه قد ينفذ تواغلا بريا
جديدا في سوريا وهو امر تعهدت القوات
الكرديه المدعومه من الولايات المتحده
بالتصدي له مقابله حتى روسيا لتركيا
بالتحلي خط النفس والامتناع عن شنه هجوم
بري واسع النطاق في سوريا
فيما تثير الضربات التركيه التوتر مع
النظام السوري ايضا اضافه الى ان تلك
الضربات التركيه اصابت مواقع لجيش النظام
السوري اسفرت عن مقتل واصابه جنود ضربات
قد تلغي الاتفاق الضني في الخصومه ضد
الاكراد السوريين بين انقره ودمشق دمشق
التي تعارض سيطره الاكراد على نحو ثلث في
اراضي البلاد ومنها الشرق الغني بالنفط
لتظلم واقع الاكراد في الشمال السوري كما
العراقيه ايضا بؤره لصراع مشتعل على
الدواء